la coalition venir québec et le parti
québécois s'engage à créer une
déclaration de revenu unique administrée
par revenu québec une solution populiste
c'est pas facile c'est beaucoup dans
l'entente ça va être long à mettre en
application ces points empochés par marc
hé bien on le fait déjà en matière de
tps tvq
on est d'ailleurs les seuls avec deux
rapports d'impôts pour les particuliers
un pur québec 1 pour ottawa les autres
provinces envoie tout à l'agencé de
revenu du canada il ya le breuvage du
québec et la grande maison paternelle de
la nage en eaux canadiennes mensuel pour
monter au milieu des années 50
à l'époque de maurice duplessis pour
comprendre le premier ministre voulait
un impôt provincial
une façon d'avoir une plus grande
autonomie fiscale de la loi de l'impôt
c'est rendu un capharnaüm puis la
majorité des citoyens ne se comprennent
pas l'ordre des comptables
professionnels agréés d'avis qu'une
déclaration unique peu importe qu'elle
soit traitée à québec ou à ottawa
représenterait indéniablement des gains
considérables pour le québec
sans pour autant limiter l'autonomie
fiscale si par exemple on rapatrie
l'impôt fédéral compte fait ici pour
faire engager plus de fonctionnaires ils
ont aucune compétence en matière
internationale
ils ont aucune compétence en matière de
régimes enregistrés le rapport de la
commission de révision permanent des
programmes suggérés en 2015 d'envisager
sérieusement à l'option d'un transfert
d'activité au gouvernement fédéral en
matière d'administration fiscale en
évoquant une économie de 400 millions de
dollars par année
les nationalistes par exemple ou encore
les sucs sont souveraines essayer de
leur expliquer sa gorge pour ce que vous
avez gagné des points nodaux le
gouvernement ce que le couillard n'y a
jamais donné suite
est ce que votre gouvernement songeait à
lui mené cette ineptie science est ainsi
arrivé c'est ça m'importe moi je vais
pas proposer ça c'est certain
je pense que dans tout le débat de
netflix à nous prouve à quel point c'est
utile d'avoir notre propre autonomie
notre capacité l'idée d'un rapport
unique c'est séduisant mais l'enjeu est
surtout politique
au lieu de proposer d'avoir une seule
déclaration d'impôt on faisait une
proposition pour simplifier
l'application des lois fiscales
je pense qu'on serait pas mal plus en
affaires
[Musique]